stop the ice cream truck gang we got a
little bit of an announcement on the
state trashy door still a few ticks left
for that second show over there in Red
Bank New Jersey scoot them up before
they're gone and you can get everything
where Kippy at Ru garbage.com gang wait
that's right Pinhead we got a bunch of
merch over there we got a lot of cool
t-shirts they're moving off the shelves
we got Zippo style lighters get them
said style not actionable zippers the
whole contractual thing at all you
garbage.com gang check it out thanks for
the support we love yous welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out if
they grow up to be classy yeah just a
big old piece of trash trash I'm your
host Dave trolley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're out back here at
tuddy's in the new edition she's
upstairs just watching a little TV okay
she's just relaxing making it easy no
trouble no nothing just chilling doing
her thing it's good smoking a little
doobie as she does yeah of course a
couple of L's Little People Sports wait
a couple of elves she's smoking blunts
but he smokes blunts now in the living
room okay yeah man a house that smokes
blunts in my co-host is coming at you
from across the table he is the CEO of
Ru garbage International businessman he
was feeding me shots last night
yeah I wanted to have a quiet night
quiet dinner he showed up with a beer
helmet on what are you talking about
this [__] guy you're a booze bag
don't blame it on me now with that Chris
O'Connor last night uh-huh boozing sure
yikes give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan
what up gang thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate if you
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
over 150 000 Subs shout out to the
[__] Army of garbage
that's what I'm talking about and
obviously the greatest gosh darn website
of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage you sign
up over there you can get up to two
bonus episodes a week you can get all
[__] plethora of videos we dropped we
dropped tour videos the Indie thing The
Cribs the this Disney everything's on
there it's all in there check it out
gang absolutely having a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the magic man makes us all look good
works the ones works the twos the threes
and the fours cry crosses the t's dots
the eyes give it up for T-Bone
mcgruffins Toby McMullen everybody hey
what up boys
another dude talk about smoking blunts
inside is something that used to make me
feel so comfortable and now makes me so
uncomfortable dude I feel like I'm in
danger when there's blunts in the car a
little bit of weed smell is
nice
um I like it a little bit
floating around it just takes me back to
all those memories I had of sitting on
like a dirty couch and some [__]
Dirtbag sure there's seeds and stems
there's a razor blade on the coffee
table oh yeah that call dude a [__]
Stoner a couple loose pistachio shells
yeah a stoner's coffee table is
something else there's res all over
something that like a pet you try to
right take a number down with a pen
there's res all over it and [__] somehow
it was worse when you're tough when you
went to your your dealer's house and you
just cleaned up it still like look feels
like a sting
what the [__]
ah yeah that ain't good man uh yeah it
just takes me back you're sitting on a
couch with like four other people have
owned before that person sure it was you
know one word's missing this was Gary's
grandma she got it from you know whoever
yeah it's I I hate it so now when I go
if I'm in a house like that it just
takes me back to like a you know not a
great time sure I used to get so so
apparently because I didn't I didn't I
didn't realize I didn't realize until
much later in life that you can just
take one little hit you'll be all right
he used to take it right to the head I
remember sitting in the back of my buddy
Charlie station wagon we cut school we
were smoking doobies and we were just
parked in a neighborhood and I had a
[__] mat I was like let's get the
[__] out of here the cops were coming I
dude the first time I hated it first
time
[__] or it might have been like the
second or third time I don't think I got
high the first time uh they say you
don't yeah I don't remember uh I don't
honestly if we weren't [__] we didn't
have any [__] kind but I know that
much just [__] mostly sees a couple
of schwickets you know what I mean
uh no but the first time I was at a
kid's house and he's like yeah we got we
got like a 25 Ace from this kid he had
it it's good money right there we're
sleeping over I'm sleeping over his
house he's like yeah I smoke weed all
the time I'm like okay cool then we get
something it's gonna be like you know we
get there and we're down the basement of
sleeping down the basement and his dad
came in and turned the lights off he's
like lights out at 10 at 10 p.m I'm
[__] I'm like dude I would [__] are
we supposed to sneak out and smoke weed
it's like a [__] it's like shawl shank
in here dude tripping over a can of
paint yeah
[__] rough hang no TV we're Junior
High no TV after 10. I was like dude
call my mom
get me the [__] out of here this sucks
goddamn news is coming on it I've get
Denise before her third glass of wine
I'm missing Atlanta was a monologue
because of you yeah I stand at a buddy's
place in Ridgewood New Jersey oh they
had a bong on the coffee table in the
living room and the mom came in and was
like you kids want snacks I was like
this is a setup you guys are feds yeah
hey Toby you smoke drugs right or what
yeah we had one strict dad there was one
dad that was really really strict sure
it was like ex-military like ex-air
force used to sleep with his eyes open
it was that guy yeah no this is creeped
me out oh dude
um nuts yeah we my dad didn't Camp I
think my dad knew everything that was
happening you know what I mean it'd be
like
I was getting the no drinking and
driving talk before I even had a car you
know what I mean it was like I don't
care if you just don't drive I'm like
all right
meanwhile he's got a [__] he's got a
[__] he's gonna [__] he's got a Rolling
Rock between his legs
those family members who used to let
them borrow your car if there was in the
show whatever and then like you're
[__] you get the car back you take a
hard turn you hear clanking under the
seat I'm like what the [__] dude
damning me I get pulled over I'm 16.
it's [__] open containers floating
around the back seat the gun underneath
there's a body in the truck I can't
don't touch that yeah
uh yeah it was um yeah those were those
weren't great days just like [__] no
you know you're just thinking about
getting weed that's all you ever thought
you know what I mean like who how can we
get a bag who's around yeah well fully's
got a full proof plan for throwing the
cops off Ascent now what's that he just
puts those glasses on I think they're
one of him oh yeah those are real cop
classes or [__] I called you Dr
Feelgood earlier
those you
[Laughter]
think you're either coming or going yeah
that's right [__] Maverick kilos are
15. yeah bro if you're the only pilot
and you're doing is under the radar and
those things when I wear these at
baseball hat in Hawaiian shirt okay I'm
working for the company
knocking over some government Nicaragua
knocking over a vending machine
[Laughter]
also too uh uh they've been talking
about the stuff Island Boys as you
brought them up we were out there last
night with uh Chris O'Connor having a
two tree Pops
I forgot we haven't made public but they
have
I have a bet with him yeah about going
down the shore well we're going down the
shore going down the shore yeah we got a
shore house with the stuff Island Boys
we're gonna go down hang out for a week
and uh I bet him I bet O'Connor says he
can do he could do the Charles he can
learn the charts he can learn the dance
the Charleston has never danced before
and I don't think he dances at weddings
or anything that kid's [__] psycho
and I don't think he's got any rhythm in
him I don't know but he's been it's a
thousand dollar bet I thought it was
500.
I we were really drunk we made this a
couple of weeks ago it was five grand no
he doesn't owe me anything he just has
to buy my beers for the week okay uh
like when we're out like he's gotta
cover my drinks but if the bet is if he
does it you got to give him a Jihad I
got to give him a Jihad I might even be
1500 or two I forget we were [__]
Jesus classified and so here's the deal
when he gets to the house
he's not allowed in until he does the
dance we'll have a Boombox play in the
song of his the Charles yeah
uh and then everybody I even took myself
out of this nice guy and I go I won't be
the one who decides if it's
good or not the the you guys will sure
so you guys decide if what he did
qualifies as the Charleston I don't know
what the hell the Charleston right yeah
I don't think you need to because he
ain't gonna do it it doesn't matter he's
got he's got two left feet she got a
dance teacher why so so I can lose money
why am I gonna get him a dance teacher
he's got to learn it he said the other
day he told me he goes I was practicing
in the shower
I was gonna show up in a cast dude yeah
I'm like okay yeah this is [__] easy
money speaking of which I've gotten to
the age where that's that's on my mind
now slipping in the bathroom or slipping
in the tub while they just put their
strips down because I almost [__] my
wife bought some honey soap or something
dude that's it turns into a goddamn
slipping I feel like the broad's in
there washing with vegetable oil [__]
dude man uh should we just put the
strips down but um so last night what is
that uh what's the etiquette on eating
in an Uber we talk about on a plane
obviously drunk obviously I had about 18
drinks in me last night yeah yeah uh
also you were I left you at the bar
which was a rare what time did you leave
there maybe like an hour after that whoa
that was late because I wanted to be out
of there by midnight and I looked at my
I hit a [__] black hole at time
because I looked at my phone it was like
dude 15. I'm like I get the [__] out of
here I was hurting yeah I was hurting
but what's can you eat an Uber and
should you ask nah yeah you should ask
but you shouldn't what were you eating
in you just said Pizza there I had a
slice of pizza there and a couple in the
car
I was gonna do pizza but then I was like
I can't get him with like a [__]
penne vodka slice or whatever [__]
stinking up this dude's [__] car
eating ramen in the bag
you got chopsticks up there but
uh it's a duck sauce situation I
couldn't bring myself to do it uh so I
did pop by the [__] that seven 11
right there sure which is I mean uh
that's crazy that's like a demilitarized
zone in there that's nuts dude I opened
I opened up all of the refrigerators
trying to get a [__] cold water to go
to night night with open up the
refrigerator it's like 95 degrees in the
hole everything was hot I was drinking a
hot Gatorade on the wall on the right oh
dude it sucked a warm Gatorade I had
that and some pretzels I ate pretzels
that's you can eat pretzels pretzels is
all right pretzels is okay I think but
you should ask I didn't
I just I'm like what are you gonna do
not let me eat pretzels I've popped a
beer in the background whoa
I vest when I first moved to New York I
Uber and I was an Uber black too they
like that I mean yes yeah [__] jerk
off in those things hey buddy you don't
want to turn around like you don't want
to miss this
um
I uh back in the day you would get those
remember before Uber you would get like
the Town Cars yeah like the hired cars
and they you would negotiate the price
you would go and be like hey we're you
know I'm here I gotta go here
how much and he'd go 40 bucks you go 25
he goes third thing you meet in the
middle sure they would especially in the
Heights Dominican dude oh you're getting
are you getting the backseat with a
12-pack they don't give a [__] you get
nine people in the back seat back there
everybody's getting [__] get the lab
going yeah I don't think can you Google
to see if what are the is there a rule
of eating in an Uber is it is not
against Uber's terms of service to eat
in the car really
[Laughter]
excuse me sir it's not in your terms and
conditions and I've read them by the way
they are I don't think they like it
yeah I I can imagine they're not fans
yeah but I don't know you ever take the
water in there if they offer you a water
that's a setup that's you're gonna
[__] wake up with your underwear on
backwards with that [__] no [__] way
dude I ain't doing that that's a [__]
setup can I tell you my new Uber
paranoia what's that when they have the
cable for the phone I never use it you
think it's gonna Jack your info yes yeah
I don't think I don't think that uh [__]
sorry dude yeah I thought that uh we're
all nuts I've thought that too
I'll do the same thing
this guy
let's start filming you in there too
yeah it's all set up they're gonna have
your nudes and stuff we'll be playing in
the Billboards at Times Square
Foley spread eagle you'll need it to see
it
better Blow That Thing Up
um yeah okay well now we know now you
don't have to you should ask though I
think that is proper or etiquette
pretzels though it's not a big thing
that's not bad dude smoking in cabs back
in the day was great I caught Philly you
could catch heaters in the cabs yeah and
they would have one yeah can I smoke in
here I'll have one too sure just like
two buds cruising around town catching
heaters hey turn this up will you
This Is My Jam if a cop comes by hold it
down yeah no problem ripping heaters
remember doing whippets in the back of a
cab one time okay going up the FDR out
of what uh ready whip like you were
doing the not even real ones not even
like the crackers
just on your way to a cookout so sorry
the pie is all [__] up on my way home
at the end of the night hurting
hurting looking for anything
keep going dude I swear I have a credit
card
that's got Buffalo Bill in the back seat
fat person you are something else dude
yeah did you ask him at least hey
buddies it cool if I do legal drugs wait
wait did you pick up the whipped cream
before or did you just have it on you no
it stopped at uh that was that was the
night cap yes yeah you were like hey I'm
gonna get a cab let me pop in get six
cans already whip yeah Jesus Christ you
gotta be ready
I got a whole pound cake at home what do
you want from me
yeah I'm No Angel
I gotta pass but you are the devil
uh God damn how do you feel about when
the Uber driver's eating oh hate it hate
it hate it that then you really feel
like you're in their car you know what I
mean I feel like this is just a guy I
asked for a ride like I'm not the guy
that we the guy that took us to the
airport in Vermont you guys were in a
pickup truck yeah he was eating chips
that's nuts do you think a whole bag of
chips like seven in the morning it was
crazy early this [__] guys eating
Funyuns
asking us how are you from what the [__]
that was crazy break out the Fritos dude
yeah that's nuts I remember I think I
told it uh uh I uh I got a cab I got an
Uber or a lift in Atlantic City and it
was a pickup truck and I had it was a
shared one like we were both going and
it was we were sitting three across yes
we were in an F-150 and the guy's like I
was talking to another couple of
farmhands I saw a guy coming home from
uh he was also from New York going to
visit family wait hold on this this was
an Uber yeah a pickup truck yeah this is
like two guys three dudes in the front
seat me and a guy were sharing it
because I I forget why we were sharing
the Uber I was go we were both going to
Wildwood like I was getting out of North
Wildwood he was going to Wildwood Crest
or something taking turns driving
everybody I've been diving up all night
yeah it was [__] wacky that was I
think that was the last time I'm like I
can't do this anymore yeah I used to
take that casino bus down there it was
30 bucks
round trip and when you got there you
got a 10 voucher to like Caesars or
something sure and man get it going when
you get in there let it ride baby I
remember oh man you're just down there
with you're dude that bus is like
it's people on the lamb any bus any bus
is brutal the Megabus from New York to
Philly was brutal yeah I never I did I
wasn't a big Mega guy uh there I was
Mega everywhere else for the most part
picked a train like a gentleman yeah I
didn't have the the money or the time
though that's it because if you don't
have that Amtrak money that could be
like a [__] four and a half hour
Journey the
New Jersey Transit train from
Penn Station Penn Station to Trenton
which is like
an hour and a half then you gotta switch
over to SEPTA that takes you in the 30th
Street this is like another hour plus
you're waiting 40 minutes for it then to
get out to The Burbs you got to get on
like the R5 or whatever and go out there
yeah yeah no that ain't worth it take
the bus down yeah I would get off at
Trenton and have someone I'd have my
mother scoop me a tree too yeah Patty
picking me up at Trenton
good old days oh by the way this is my
nine year anniversary of living in New
York speaking of this congratulations
nine years today
look at you uh-huh I remember when you
stumbled into the city yeah looking at
me for advice showing you the roads no
the first day we got lost you got us on
the wrong train we went to a movie
no he didn't we didn't I was at a movie
I went to a movie by myself and met you
a real cool guy it was uh because we we
met in Chelsea
I forgot yeah I don't know I just
remember you being like yeah let's go
pop over this show I know so and so's on
the show we're only three you're like
we're on a training like this ain't the
right train we got him I'm like this guy
stinks dude meanwhile you're smoking all
my heaters when I lived when I was
kidding for 20 bucks probably wind up in
the Bronx I'm gonna go talk to a guy in
the corner real quick
I gotta see a man about a tie
why are we at the ready whip Factory
I got a big one
not even a case you have one giant one
um
what was I gonna say when I lived up
here the first time I never learned the
subway system I never took the subway I
would take the bus occasionally but I
usually took cabs or didn't go anywhere
don't move her and shake her
there was like two years where I didn't
leave the Upper East Side I worked in
the Upper East Side my apartment was in
the Upper East Side I didn't really do
anything if I went anywhere I was going
somewhere with my brother and I was
taking a cab so I had to learn to sit I
had to learn the subway when we when we
moved up here yeah it wasn't easy a
couple of Tears shed on that Subway I'll
tell you that yeah yikes a lot of what
am I doing the whole nine yards it ain't
great those first couple of months six
first everybody says the first year but
at like nine months you're like oh this
just never it's just only gonna get
worse like everything sucks everything
yeah God damn Jam you up Jamie up now
here we are look at us now thanks to
Anthony baby yeah let's jump in the Turn
Style no more I never ever did that [__]
I was always afraid I wouldn't give him
the satisfaction I only said excited I
assumed that you had a story of you
getting clipping your feet and falling
off no that's why he didn't do it my
school bag would get caught I'd [__]
I'd hang up upside down or something
that that's why I wouldn't do it I'm so
injury prone you're hanging there like
Jesus
so I never [__] did it dude I assume
that was your Mo what jump a turn signs
yeah been known to spray painting cops
and jumping turnstiles hey buddy stay
still for a second
[__] law breaker
the roller skates yeah I never [__]
with that
yeah never never never okay let's talk
about Helix
let's talk about the best night's sleep
that we've ever had together dang not a
lot of sleeping I mean a big man we're
knocking boots only best way to do it
any Helix mattress gang do yourself a
favor get over to helix.com get on there
take the quiz two three minutes find out
exactly how you like to sleep let me
tell you something sleep is very very
important important between the Helix
and my CPAP oh I feel like a million
bucks you look like [__] uh me and the
wife took it to the good folks the hook
sent them to me they sent it a big man
me an old wife what the hell you said
you were single
uh being the wife took it we got the we
got we got matched up with the Twilight
series fantastic I'm snoozing a little
awake I'm rubbing my rubbing my tootsies
together there you go just take the
Sleep quiz get match under two minutes
whether you need extra cushion for your
spine cooling features to keep it from
overheating they have you covered at
Helix baby big boys they got you covered
too and right now
here's the turkey Hills is offering 20
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com garbage that's
helixsleep.com garbage this is their
best offer yet and it won't last long
ladies and gentlemen with Helix better
sleep starts now go check it out do it
Kim how about that bespoke post uh I
think you mean box of also yeah bespoke
post box of awesome get cool stuff sent
to your house on a monthly basis you got
the fall you got the winter you got the
spring you got the summer they shot they
break it all up maybe get a cool pocket
knife maybe you get a cool tent maybe
get some grooming stuff some of that
cool soap or something like some Pine
something to make a nice cocktail with
too step your [__] bar game up bozos
all small Brands helping small
businesses passing savings right on you
yeah uh they sent me some sweet knives I
gotta be honest with you I just got a
green pocket knife look at you and I
feel so I I live in an apartment I don't
really have I don't really have use for
them out of Woodsman anymore I'm a city
dweller but man I can open up an Amazon
package and I feel I feel like Crocodile
Dundee out of here I'm like Zorro taking
your top off it's not a forehead
H H box is valued at around 70 and 90 of
everything that comes in your box of
awesome like the big man said it's from
a small up and coming brand look at that
get 20 off your first monthly box when
you sign up at box of awesome.com enter
the code garbage at checkout that's box
of awesome.com code garbage for 20 off
your first box box of awesome.com code
garbage do it gang
um but that's neither here nor there
gang cause we got a gosh darn fast
Family episode on our hands we do when
you sign up for patreon we will answer
your garbage question on the air it's
just the best way to do it the homies
get first crack at it so sign up over
there on that patreon it's a good good
God darn time having fun over there yes
it's a [__] though that's sauce [__]
there's over 9 000 patrons it's good
shout out to you may Army garbage is
strong I feel all fuzzy wuzzy something
else a love from them baby something
else uh all right let's see here this
one's from Josh are you garbage if in
Middle School your principal got beat up
by a kid
that's [__] tough dude you gotta quit
Jay you gotta quit you gotta get demoted
to teacher or something
nah weed Mr Schneider he'd knock you the
[__] out really he was huge Stand By Me
type [__] yeah
Hank got your ass in your fat ass
hanging off the top of the building and
this is the 90s man all our teachers
were like tough in some way there was
none of that
I remember my ninth grade science
teacher jacking somebody up for saying
his name wrong he was really on the edge
of Jesus he was our Athletics up a decaf
will you doc Doyle shout out to him
R.I.P [__] great dude he's taught me
about the Gatorade
diluted 2-1
okay that's all I learned about hey guys
[__] real scholar over here
the only thing you learned about learned
in high school was about food but he was
usually on the edge and some kid came
and was like your doc uh doc boiled
doctor and all sudden he just lost it
and jacked him up he's like you [__]
making fun of me you plotting on me boy
ah ah yeah that's nuts
we didn't have uh I don't think any my I
did have a extended family member uh who
would
uh if I don't know it was like a charter
school private was like a you know some
not a public school and
he would go if you you know he had
taught like teenagers or whatever and he
was like Hey you know you're getting
like arguments like you know and he was
like if you want to [__] have it out
I'll square you know not square up with
you I think they would go to the gym and
he would just like beat the [__] out of
these kids he's like you're getting a
line well [__] you know we'll [__]
shoot the fate or whatever and then
we'll air out our differences and we'll
go back to class yeah I was like that's
[__] I don't think he's a I don't
think he's teaching anymore by one
teacher uh would do that if students got
into a fight
again this is this is the early 90s you
should take his shirt off and jump in
how you [__]
starts
jump the kid
run his pockets afterwards
only three measly bucks I did this [__]
for him that's the worst when they go
through your pockets oh man yeah yeah
um no uh two kids got into a beef made
everybody pull all the dust back and and
into a square and put them in the middle
I was like go ahead but they were too
too scared to fight yeah oh yeah at that
point oh no because you're getting in
trouble oh yeah anyway yeah yeah yeah no
uh yeah we never I and I think another I
think I think we had a wrestling coach
who would you know it was the gym
teacher and if you got [__]
if he got into it with him he was like
I'll [__] you know let's take it to the
mats I'll [__] you know how to
[__] give you the button hook or
whatever
whatever you want a folding chair
and it's Mr Jenkins from the top rope
[__] you hit him with a leg drop
he runs in and puts the face paint on it
comes out the lights go out
Stephanie McMahon running around back
down
that's her name right uh maybe I think
so uh I don't think it's definitely
doesn't it kind of does sound right but
it's also I don't think it is Stephanie
or Stacy Stephanie Stephanie look at you
you still watching no I just saw a clip
of uh her and uh Triple H Vince McMahon
well a couple days ago okay gotcha
gotcha gotcha ah [__] home run of a
question home run
um all right this one's for Marty uh 10
homie never have one red is it garbage
to ask your friend where are you staying
instead of where are you living
real real temporary Vibes there that
means you're on your way out that's not
permanent where are you staying a couch
yeah I'm staying over at my mom's I'm
staying over at hoodies that's that's
somebody getting their [__] together
I've done that staying somewhere yeah
where are you staying I was back at
Patty's uh when I flunked out of school
before I left for theater School I was I
was staying there for a little while
that's what you tell but I'm staying in
my mouth yeah I'm helping out oh yeah
you know yeah yeah I paid a rent paid a
mortgage all that stuff
Patty I'm gonna have to break your legs
and the story stays solid it's like
misery
I could see you at the Town bar trying
to land some [__] Bluebell four yeah
I'm staying with Ma you know did you
ever bring your girl back to your mom's
house like after college and stuff like
that yeah no like to try to close a deal
no we always went out in Philly so like
we would go like we had Apartments sure
we were like that's like where we would
go out no never I never had like sneak
someone in yeah
[__] trying to run to set the alarm
before the alarm goes off my dad was a
light sleeper
makes you doing more
come back this bbds
shout out to bbds by the way they were
something else that was the gentleman's
underwear yeah I was like that was like
fancy and classy I know because I
remember I went we like went swimming I
was like a young kid I don't know
[__] you were a tighty whities man
right like just I think everybody starts
out as a tiny white yeah dude yeah right
yeah you can't be doing he can't be a
three-year-old in boxers
get the socks with the straps
I mean I told you I I was like eight or
nine I used to wear a pair of silk
boxers that but I was over my buddy's
house we went swimming I think like
impromptu swimming so like I didn't have
clothes we were probably I don't seven
six something like that and so she was
like I'll just you know his mom was like
I'll just use you know uh uh like a pair
of his underwear and shorts or whatever
and I remember she handed she like she's
like okay here you go like go up and
shower what a change she handed me a
pair of bvbs and I I never heard of them
things I was I thought they were Euro
cut or something I was like they had a
real thick strap
what are we professional wrestlers
he got me out here looking like Val
Venus steal these from Superman
yeah I remember being like I ain't never
heard of that brand I was a weird we
were Haynes Haynes Haynes Fruit of the
Loom sure yeah yeah
bvds yeah man didn't fill those things
out I'll tell you that much yeah it was
like a Van Heusen you know those shirts
the van heusen's yeah they're Macy's
right yeah they were nice a couple of
Van usings like a real sharp dude the
summer between my senior year of high
school and going to college my
girlfriend at the time came down and
stayed with me and my folks and we
hooked up and I went out we went out to
the pool or whatever and my mom's dog
little Maltese you had a pool in the
apartment complex yeah okay that's a
caveat yeah okay
you had a pool guys Three Doors Down
then they were on vacation they were in
Spain for the month
the the her Maltese went through the
trash and came out into the living room
with the used condom in its mouth
throwing it around the living room dude
like something about Mary or some [__]
dude
looking like a Subway rapper
the [__] big dog
let the old man know
hey seen that thing
huh
what a little perv of a dog
all the stuff in there that's what you
go for
it's like a little heathen
oh freak
you would knock boots in the house like
that not after that Jesus I got this
narcass dog running around blowing my
spot up I only did that once in [__]
my dad heard and he was [__] it does
you don't have a house can you don't
even have a head [__] house conducive
to wailing on yourself let alone [__]
having a partner doing the dosey doe up
there it was a Gestapo regime in there I
mean all the doors are oddly connected
it's like a hotel they're all adjoining
rooms kind of come on open it up to the
outside
yeah yeah that ain't an easy sneak in
and sneak out were you allowed to so
okay so you said between high school and
college what state is this in oh you're
in Florida same piece St Pete were you
was your high school girlfriend allowed
to sleep in your room uh sleep over yes
really we were adults basically kind of
you're not an adult now what are you
tall you weren't an adult back then
legally my mom yeah he was a big ass
Sprout legally you can't tell me what to
do now I'll take my cereal in my room
please
we had cousins in their 20s and if they
weren't married they weren't allowed to
sleep in the same room with their uh
with their fiances
the Catholic household like I Love Lucy
that Zephyr beds one foot on the floor
no he put one downstairs and one
upstairs yeah my there was a there was a
moment girls sleep in your room hey
shout out to atheism
I guess there is benefits your parents
are atheists yeah
okay I thought you heard Scottish
got 23andMe on this guy
I think my brother-in-law lived it what
does that have to do with anything
regardless household man no rules baby
yeah all the all the stuff we have is
all Catholic yeah [__] disgrace yes
you know what I mean
my brother-in-law needed a place to stay
tell you knock a broad up that's I think
that's why Patty didn't want it
happening
you want me [__] dropping live rounds
in somebody
She's Gotta raise the kid because I had
no we stopped talking about your rounds
please
upstairs watching TV
uh there's no more round talk from you
all right and if you're on the patreon
you know why I bring that up because
they've seen them
seen a couple of spin clips
big man's in there dumping Clips in his
undies it wasn't that
it was ready whip
[Laughter]
[Music]
this one's from E Breezy from vacate
Vacaville uh ten dollar homie never had
one red
um this is a shot at me in a picture I
post are you garbage but I didn't
realize are you garbage if you get no
sideburns when getting your hair cut
especially if you're a child with no
sideburns that picture I posted with the
bowl cut I didn't realize I they took me
the [__] high in Tights I had the
flatliner going dude that's a bad look
it was worse when a dad had it oh man a
grown man with it
it's you see the sunglasses go all the
way back yeah
um I saw a dude on the train with it
dude he went so high up in the back you
know what I mean like they think they
[__] took him all the way up and he
had no no [__] sideburns I was like
buddy go open a book or something read a
magazine it's not a good look it's not a
good look but I get it at the time I
don't think things were we've talked
about this things weren't cool back then
because we didn't know anything no they
were it was cool back then I don't think
it was cool I just thought it was
baseball players that had it I didn't
have the baseball I didn't have the cool
hot Dominican baseball guy no no I'm
talking I'm talking about the white guys
they would have like regular regular
hairline like on the side just take it
off and they would just be gone
there's a couple guys on the Expos the
Reds that had it I don't know that's a
tough look though yeah that's a real
that's real jammed up another tough look
is the bald guy with the sideburns that
go too high
sure what do you mean you know how like
if they have a beard and you clip it by
the ears then it does it fades into the
shaved head but sometimes you'll see it
go up a little too high like the way
Action Bronson rocks it a little bit
yeah he pulls it off but like past their
ears yeah so it's just like you just got
like two [__] Jones here oh yeah what
the [__] yeah it's like Mad Max [__]
yeah yeah it's like reverse mutton chops
kind of
inverted chops
yeah that's a tough look
um all right let's see here this one's
from Frank another ten dollar homie uh I
already know how I feel about this but
is it garbage to put your shirt on
before boxers my dad did this growing up
and definitely saw him dangling as a
child your shirt before your boxer crazy
yeah Chrissy D does it real oh that's
right yeah that's right Winnie the poos
it is I feel like I need to be protected
right away sure you know what I mean
yeah like having your you know undies go
on first yeah so I can [__] get my
wits about me yeah yeah and he's going
first that's that's crazy yeah that's
that ain't that ain't great uh dads did
a real weird [__] back then they had
real weird routines and all that yeah
there was it was no man's land they
weren't talking they were just figuring
it out themselves yeah
high white socks bad deodorant
shitty underwear big time
uh Tucker T was all tidy way did you get
like the Shaving Converse did your dad
show you how to shave uh
uh I think maybe once but I couldn't
shave the way he could he had like a
real like man stubble
my my even now it's not really thick
does that make sense yeah I think it's
because they didn't moisturize or
something that skin was different that
was like a catcher's changed every day
could you imagine because like it made
it would like make noise yeah dude
yeah I didn't have that you were ripping
a piece of loose leaf yeah I think my
dad shaved every day nuts
it's nuts that's so crazy to me I hated
shaving I hate the way it made made my
face feel I just stopped one time like
not to like right before I was getting
married I was just like I'm [__]
because I would be so lazy that I would
let it get too long and I didn't have a
beard trimmer I just would I had to like
it'd be too long be ripping out some old
old mach3 and whatever oh yeah it would
hurt I would feel it here for days I was
just like [__] it'd be weird when it
was growing back in no I could feel it
being already like ripped it just
[__] sucked and I was like I'm done
I'm just getting I thought beard
trimmers were catch your lip I thought
beard trimmers were like a million
dollars they're awesome and then I
remember I bought one did you know
anybody that rocked the electric razor
there's the ones with the circle my
stepdad had one but I don't think I
think he just bought it because it was
like it was never used I don't know how
those things work I used it one time it
was [__] brutal I thought they were
exclusively for guys at red lights in
commercials or movies late for a meeting
that's funny Kim you know about this
mint mobile uh yeah mid mobile my wife's
been using it for years so you know
about 15 a month keep your number pass
the savings right out of the consumer
all done online no brick and mortar no
pushy sales people no nothing like that
oh by the way you know who owned it Ryan
Reynolds you ever get a peek at that guy
tight body
uh yeah mint mobile 4 goes the
traditional cost of retail by passing
The Savings straight to you so you
choose there you go uh all plans come
with unlimited talk text and high-speed
data on a nation's largest 5G Network
trash here to say data or data uh data
is trashier yeah it would be data I'm a
data man oh I'm a data man I don't know
how would I do actually now I'm in my
head about it switching couldn't be
easier keep your same phone phone number
and all your contacts the only thing
that changes is your bill and it goes
down a bunch of monies okay 15 beans
what are we doing I know 15 bucks a
month not even saving 15 bucks it's 15
bucks a month crazy it's uncanny uh to
get your new Wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month and get that plan shipped
to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com garbage that's
mintmobile.com garbage cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com
show Gang back to the show did any of
your dads wear the sock suspenders
no I don't understand no with the straps
I was just saying no that's for like
business people what do you mean in the
20s nobody why did yours no it was a
traveling salesman
selling snake oil but that's for suits
right that's the keep that's to keep the
suit no I I think that was Whitey's I
think that was when they didn't have
elastic and socks
yeah but I feel like people did it way
even with dress like you know at least
you see it in movies and [__] where like
or maybe that's just like a a Trope I
don't know I don't know
I don't know never a fan never a fan of
suspenders either I tried to pull them
off I think in like eighth grade whoa
yeah grunge now
just wanted to wear a suspension I think
it was because of uh uh it was because
somebody did it cool right Robin
Williams wore suspenders on Mork and
Mindy and I want I wanted to fork and
Mindy
they were rainbow too
trying to pull it off
nah man how long did it take to get the
wedgie out from the bully
did they gave you a wedgie oh sure just
[__] jacked you up I remember I also
tried overalls for a little bit they
were I think I had it my sister would
wear them in the Earl I guess look at my
sisters or I guess my sister's younger
than you
but there was I remember her being in
like Junior High and like they were
rocking overall like the Calvin Klein or
Tommy Hill figure I think they had like
the Branded sure yeah no these were the
years were like country overall yeah it
was bad
like you're running the General Store
it's no good
but that and when carpenter jeans hit
man you couldn't tell me [__] nice set
of Carpenters I looked horrible in those
things look horrible and everything what
are we talking about
um they were huge nice set of carpenter
jeans though you couldn't go back to
regular jeans you felt like a nerd you
know what I mean at least when I back
when I was banging yeah I was too old
for them to be walking around with them
I just look like a carpenter sure yeah I
had them yeah I had to work arbiter
they were great for uh
uh the one one because they started
making the pockets a little bigger it
would have like the loop on the one side
like the hammer yeah that was it they
had the pockets then they would be like
Tupac for like a utility knife and a
pencil or whatever sure but I had a pair
that was put your weed in there perfect
for a pack of heaters [__] sneak it
right down in there man let me operate
in school no one knew none the
difference because they used to be able
to like search your bags and shoes you
had heaters on you in school you sure
did dude why not
I needed one
yeah for after school that's crazy what
do you mean
I was an athlete I was a [__] smoking
heaters like a bozo most kids that were
smoking heaters
we're had heaters on them micro ran deep
with heaters really yeah in Heist hat
flip everybody and then once you were
driving you had them in your car sure
[__] light up as you're pulling out
come get me copper [__] spark up yeah
of course you gotta have your heaters on
you no jammed up no heaters when
somebody would would somebody in class
would sneak out and go rip a heat that's
crazy in the stairwell my buddy my buddy
used to do it all the time he'd go and
[__] pull one in the bathroom and
dude he would uh-huh dude [__] suck
it down and come rolling in casually but
at back then everybody smelled like
smoke too no that you you you could
everybody knew of course but I'm just
saying there were still smoking sections
and [__] like everybody was smoking yeah
I was trying to think of why I a teacher
that smoked oh we gotta teacher so did
we Mr Moore you could see the nicotine
staying on his [__] on his mustache
his mustache was like tie-dye dude it
was [__] dude those guys seemed like
they didn't leave school like they were
just there all the time they wore the
same thing they always had chalk on them
yeah this guy was all mister I think it
was Mr reinmiller he was always chewing
gum he smelled like cigarettes and mint
we had one guy with the same page he got
I remember I might have said this he got
a pair of cargo cargo pants a pair of
green khaki cargo pants
fat piece of [__] such every I [__]
hated this dude [__] real loud mouth
he was always see him around [__]
chirping and [__] it's like buddy
[__] zip it or write some new
material will you uh call the teacher
aloud
laughs
okay a real [__] attitude problem
real show-off
he was a [__] loudmouth
and he will dude he got them he came
back first day from Christmas break with
this freshly [__] fresh set of
[__] green cargo shorts and then wore
them every single day for the rest of
the year to the point where shorts no
cargo pants
wearing shorts get the [__] out of here
we saw a teacher got his wife uh
his fiancee broke off with him or
something like midday first of all
dick move yeah he's guys trying to mold
the minds of the future and you're
[__] out there cheating on him or
whatever playing with his heart
little Philly breaker
walk down on you
um she was a dime store [__] you don't
need her trying to comfort him uh yeah
so he dude he just started bawling shut
the [__] I swear to God I wasn't my he
was right next to me we started crying
in class it's a teacher teacher would be
weird if it was a student let's get
married
teacher he starts bawling right and then
you're in the middle of class I'm not in
the class I'm in the class right next
door
okay right so like those are doors it
was like a pod no there's doors but like
there was Windows into like right by
whatever whatever we see them leave it
like you can hear that you can feel it's
very close to us okay we feel there's
something of a foot sure there's a
there's a hoopla these kids are [__]
you know what I mean [__] you're
probably running his pockets at this
point
dude it's got nothing to live for I'm
taking his lunch
um they [__] so he runs out and I
think he you can't leave until you can't
leave a class unattended like state law
or sure so he had to like call there was
like a phone in the back oh there's a
phone in the hallway that's what it was
so he had to go out on this is when we
saw him because the phone was right next
to our door he's crying on the phone
going okay this sounds so under room 502
I'm having a bad day or whatever and
then dude now everybody's like [__]
everybody's [__] leaning into the guy
and then until we graduated high school
that was it was like remember when Mr so
and so [__]
ouch that is heartbroken we had a uh
open your books it's a chapter four
oh on the board
that's breaking up the acoustic [__]
there we go
um did you have any teachers that were
married or in a relationship in your
school together yeah
no my junior year
um there was uh two teachers that were
married
dude uh had an affair with another
teacher in the school Caliente yeah
French teacher
homewrecker oh I lied Miss homewrecker
there was a hot teacher I believe or
language something from the romance you
know uh a romantic language
and that Slavic [__] she she hooked
up with uh uh single but like uh you
know a guy and they got together I
remember it was the Talk of the Town
sure everybody had a thing for her
doggy Mr lady just grabbed her I had
some [__] I was waiting until I was
waiting until I turned 18 to make my run
but somebody yeah and I remember
everybody was like
man The One That Got Away you know what
I mean
I was just close
um all right let's see here uh this
one's from William is it garbage if your
Grandpa took a shot of Fireball during
church services because he had a cough
and that's what he calls is cough
medicine oh
now
grandparents drinking Fireball trash
makes no sense because when they were
banging there was no Fireball yeah
that's newly adopted yikes but it does
have a smoothing uh sure I do get that
it is like a lozenge there's a reason
that cough medicine has alcohol in it
yeah I don't know what it is but
I'm sure it's something does it have
alcohol in it yeah usually
I mean now they have a little different
stuff but back in the day it had alcohol
in it hey for sure I got a year-round
call if you know what I mean big guy I
know that because my my uncle was an
alcoholic and he couldn't have cough
medicine
really yeah I think because is there
alcohol in there or just something in it
that alters your state T-Bone I saw big
eyes from T-Bone CVS Health nighttime
cough syrup contains 10 alcohol damn
let's get a sixer that's a [__] white
cloth yeah no
wait why claws like six
yeah if you drink ten percent you'd have
to drink the bottle 10 alcohol by volume
which is different than the bottle no
you're not a [__] [__]
[__] weekend warrior I'm gonna throw
in it baby
five percent a white claw has
double a white claw
shout out to cough medicine
kids no don't do that out there that's
bad of course
um but adults
[Laughter]
still don't do it no no stop don't say
it it's a funny joke but don't say it
just drink beer okay everybody oh
where's my butter
hey yeah it's legal
cough medicine's legal not like that
it's not they wouldn't sell it to you if
they knew what you were doing with it
yeah Robitussin and soda
come here tossing on the rocks
Splash it grandma yay oh man uh okay
let's see here this one's from tatted
Steve is it garbage to carry two phones
because one has a cracked screen and use
it wait hold on I'm sorry is it garbage
to use two phones because one has a
cracked screen and using it as a hot
spot for the other phone which doesn't
have service
I don't even get that that's still not
even a full working phone anywhere no
so the hot spot so the hot spot he's got
a cracked he's got a broken phone that
has service
right he then uses the hot spot on that
to connect a phone that a dead phone
that doesn't have service right why not
just switch the phone somehow can't you
like just go and be like I want this
phone it's obviously a dirt ball he's
just got this is the epitome of jammed
up by the way I've been jammed up like
that for a while before I got an iPhone
which was maybe I didn't get an iPhone
until probably until 2017. okay
um
I had some [__] real real bad phones
you remember any of those phones that I
had I had like old [__] Androids and
[__] [__] like that are you a
Blackberry guy yeah I had blackberries
were cooking I had the worst Blackberry
ever it was all [__] up the top was
gone
the top of the top plastic part was gone
I think I remember that yeah when did
you get an iPhone like 2017. that was my
first time whoa
yeah
that long ago I mean that recent yeah
all right when did you guys get one
2014 2015. they dropped when 2006
something like that so I'm like that
wasn't I remember I remember the kid
that had one at a party 2007. that
sounds of six or seven I've ever seen
one at the restaurant that I worked at
I was like look it was like the future I
talked so much sitting there with your
overalls on what's that sir I talked so
much [__] about it there was a drug
dealer who lived above me I was like why
do I need that and he goes I'm trying to
watch YouTube while I'm taking a [__]
and I was like I'm solved again
huh
2017 got my first iPhone which it was
like immediately stolen sure like six
months later I had to blouse a
Blackberry guy because BBM was big do
you remember BBM you were probably too
much of a dirt bag that was like
iMessage but for Blackberry you had like
a code yeah and you'd be like I just got
my brother's old one from work he was a
big Blackberry guy oh yeah I mean work
like the business they had to be
Blackberry yeah yeah yeah ping in all
that kind of I remember them talking
about in an Entourage
really blackberries yeah I got one uh
and then I moved to the sidekick slide
there we go the middle remember the
sidekick Lil Wayne calling when you want
call me on my sidekick that was Fallout
Boy [__] I didn't [__] with any of that
stuff Fallout Boy I just lumped that in
there with the with the early 2000s he's
not wrong big with the Myspace kids yeah
really oh yeah I thought it was a
sidekick I thought it was like a uh it
was a hip-hop thing now they were
rapping about stock call me when you
want [__] call me on my sidekick no
there was even an emo band who had a
song that was called
can I check my MySpace when we get there
it was about like getting a psychic
really you were one of those hats that
all the girls wore too
what the Von Dutch hats wait what do you
mean the one that um
Judd Apatow's wife wears in uh we were
just watching the 40 bucket hats but
dude that was my phone that the middle
part split up exposed a whole keyboard
had the tracking ball on whatever I
thought could you watch videos on it
ah yeah but like through the browser
this wasn't there wasn't like YouTube
apps on it at this point this was like
through the browse I thought I was Jay-Z
with this thing dude I thought I was the
coolest [__] kid in the world slide
that thing open goldfish fall out
I mean some [__] barbecue sauce all
over it I remember when the razors hit
yeah
speaking of that my brother
got one for Christmas and he's like oh
[__] this year
about [__] 15 years ago or whatever
and he's like oh his I think he is
a girlfriend or whoever it was or
somebody got him and he's got him like
the you know Motorola Razer when they
were like the [__] the colored ones
whatever and he's like oh cool the new
razor had something like that purple
yeah couldn't tell her nothing yeah
every [__] out of color
Daddy I love you but I had to make the
joke he opens the door
I love you Patty
yeah
PT Cruiser
your [__] tattoos
who are you talking about your mama or
me I don't know but she's gonna go home
and clean herself up I'll pay you back I
picture with the [__] with the purple
razor in those leather pants foreign
I've told you that right
man that's so have you ever have you
ever talked to her about it now she
doesn't remember yeah I talked to her
about it and that's how long ago she's
like that never happened real selective
memory yeah so do you by the way I don't
know what you're talking about you
forgetting you had lunch already
speaking of which is something to eat
you know
a little bit peckish
that's [__] funny
the razor
looking back to early 2000s man
some of those styles were pretty whack
mm-hmm pretty whack
yeah I remember I spent all of I
whatever credit limit Macy's gave me to
get my credit card I got like a dude I
remember trying to buy I trying to be
cool in college that's when like cool
clothes started Dr like very not cool
clothes but working like the Affliction
t-shirts like those graphic tees a
Blazer I was wearing that [__] what five
years after it was cool you remember my
graphic tees down in Philly yeah I mean
you're still off the mark a lot but
yeah I don't know what I thought about
you when I first met I didn't love you I
know that much it wasn't uh you were
you had to grow on me a little bit yeah
I just think all around
we're running around in that [__]
suit jacket like you were [__] Bob
barkers
what the [__] were you thinking
I like the nice suit Jack the nice
Blazer I got all my Uncle Mike's old
clothes and I would just I just wore
them
he would roll through stuff
everything starts to the eyebrows yeah
[__] cut your neck hey what's up guys
yeah I got all of his old suits I got
all his old golf shirts all that [__]
that's what I wore I remember you're a
very uh
eclectic guy a lot of weird haircuts
floating around you even did that on
this show all they some of like tag-ins
and you're like shaved head you got a
ponytail there's a lot going on yeah
I could see you being a real bald guy
with a ponytail late in life sure comic
book you can make that work the comic
book store guys I'd never do a ponytail
and I ain't gonna bald
right now me on the other hand
Toby hit me
you should grow it all out uh-uh
that'd be cool what grow it out yeah
um what no I'm just gonna I'm gonna like
I always said I want to do the what's
Agora did just as he gets just keep it
shorter and shorter as it gets it's
still in Prime game I get I get nice
compliments I mean I got a lot of mean
compliments a lot of mean comments as
well it's holding its ground yeah it's
holding its ground some people say it
looks more fortified than ever you're
off the Rogaine or on a Rogaine I'm on
the Rogaine I'm off to pro peace gotcha
uh
that shit's dug in like World War one
yeah trench warfare baby
Rogaine I I used to consider Rogaine my
boots mustard gas floating around up
there
Rogaine was my bunch of dead horses
flies there's just flies around it
that's always [__] up with those World
War One photos it was like four dead
horses laying there oh man
oh my God what war no man's lands war
with horses yeah
poor bastards
um [__] what was I say Flanders Fields
um all right let's see here uh this
one's from Benjamin oh shout out Benny
boy uh
uh subcontractor of kippy's heaters and
cooling here shout out to you uh welcome
to the company uh are you garbage no
Benny's with that job nah subconscious
subcon you're 10.99 independent don't
forget about that yeah I'm not I'm not
carrying [__] we're not taking our
taxes for you nah that's all you're on
your own you need to write off keep your
receipts
um
um are you garbage if you're the same
age as your brother without being twins
brother was born late January and I was
born in December of the same year so for
that month we're both the same age
I didn't even think that was a
possibility how long do you have to wait
until I mean they waited a month no two
months maybe she was pregnant within two
months it has to be right because what's
nine months from
wait hold on September no why September
September is nine months from January my
late January
no it's yeah no on the other end so
what's
wait the brother was born in late
January yeah so okay yes born in early
December
so so February March April May June July
August September October November
they're 11 months apart I think that's
not crazy I've never heard of anybody no
that is crazy the same age as your
brother call them Irish twins no that's
18 months yeah I'm Irish twins 18 months
is Irish twins me my brother 18 months
which means they'd be [__]
that's
the same age as same mom
that's nuts probably a piece so wait
what are they one side Junior let me in
there
the old man couldn't keep his hands on
her she for sure has a purple razor uh
[Laughter]
uh yeah no that's
that hurts my head
that shouldn't be legal
it's gonna be sore down there so how
long is it after after you give birth
three weeks three weeks three weeks you
can get pregnant yeah Jesus
there you buried that one huh hello
three weeks you're back on also what
kind of freak is he it's like throwing a
hot dog down a hallway probably I Think
Jesus Christ
that's
18 I mean my brother and sister 18
months that's Irish Google it see if
they give you time for Irish twins I
think it's 18 to 20 months and that
that's what I'm saying and that's fast
so much so that it has a name sure you
know what I mean
uh two children's space 12 or fewer
months apart
fewer 12 or fewer so you guys aren't
Irish twins no no Irish cousins kissing
cousins
so they're Irish twins yeah whoa I
always thought Irish terms was 18 months
all right me too all right you learned
something new every day the Irish
um all right let's see this is from the
prince on the fat horse
and that is a European homie shout out
to you he's a 13 Euro homie
that would be the pound [__] yeah bam
maybe Scottish right Scotland no
Scotland's got to use the pound too
Scotland uses the pound well
I gotta go on my face yeah damn I like
that they're back on the pound
not for any political reason just pounds
are cool
Euros are cool too I look fake though
yeah don't look at real money I don't
feel like real money either yeah I can't
remember who's on that too
on the Euro yeah I mean probably a lot
of people there's a lot of different
bills I think it's the same person
I know it ain't the queen I'll tell you
that much
hey lady kick rocks huh
yeah it's probably just like all you
know different political figures from
the past what do you got who's on a 20.
I'm checking right now I'm not getting
great answers
huh
It's gotta be yeah like old you know
somebody somebody it's I feel like you
gotta think it's a new currency when I
was in France I feel like Winston
Churchill was on one of them that would
make sense though right I don't think so
huh
hey Steve Martin that John Candy
a couple of John candies uh it's a
building
it's not even a guy what
get out of here with that that makes
sense though what building just a CVS
I'm checking it's not giving me great
answers yes but Johnny on a spot the
whole episode this is stumping you
I mean I don't think it's him uh it's
just goddamn European internet man
he's translating it on the Fly they
don't want to they don't want to call
off the info up
um are you garbage if you reenacted
jackass Don's end or Home Alone traps
that's always I mean jackass yeah that
hit when we were uh when I was I mean
Sam with T-Bone young teenager that was
you know
before you get your hands on a shopping
cart you're sure you're pushing a buddy
in that yeah what do you got T-Bone it's
a fake building a fake building yeah
it's uh the 20-year-old banknotes to
pick Bridges and arches slash doorways
in a Gothic architecture
what the [__] that's kooky I ain't going
back there tell you that much if I do
I'm spending greenbacks USA box Daddy-o
a couple of t-bills Treasury bonds
um s p oh they'll take it yeah you
better if you want my business
uh but Home Alone traps that's what you
wanted as a kid you wanted to [__]
booby-trap the house and [__] some dudes
up sure what age were you when that drop
though you were aged out of that when
did Home Alone come out probably 89 no
92 92 I was a sophomore in high school
yeah it'd be weird if you were [__]
had a BB gun on your back [__]
1990 1990. so I was in uh eighth grade
that's right around yeah that's all
right you were four
yeah you were you watching that when you
were four I mean that I don't I don't
know I don't know if I was at the
premiere but if I can I did it was an
integral part of my childhood probably
give you a blonde-haired kid named Kevin
what are we doing here that was me baby
sure yeah I don't I mean okay so it came
out when 90 yeah so I would have been uh
14 the old guy still scared me oh he
scares me now oh like I I I I understand
them a little bit more as I get older
great actor yeah great performance man
he's so good in the end those boots
little bastard eating pizza oh dude
[__] no way dude I that pizza looked
all right I'll tell you that shout out
to little neros it was a little near us
of course yeah a little nearer that and
I would always try to find like the uh
something in the movie where you could
scare somebody the talk boy who got
became huge he had the recording that
[__] thing didn't work like that as a
student as a [__] six-year-old I
might as well have been working for the
[__] CIA
are you nuts Jason Tim Curry yeah I was
[__] bugging the house just [__]
you know I was doing everything trying
to find out what I was getting for
Christmas
tree Jerry Lewis you leave a running
paper quarter in the room metallic clink
all right we gotta go dang I'm gonna
tell you this right now we love you to
death oh yeah come see us on the road
we're about to drop a couple of the
second leg of the tour sure she'll be
dropping soon check out Ru garbage.com
pick yourself up a d lighter whatever
you want we love you very much and we'll
see you next week peace